people of the internet's retro reckons
who are here it is now official as you
guys already know this week we are
finally getting the playstation showcase
will hogwarts legacy is this the moment
guys is this what we've been waiting for
are we finally going to get more
information on this game remember we
just had that playstation sizzle reel
trailer a few weeks ago where they
showed glimpses of hogwarts legacy
surely surely they don't put that in
there if they're not planning to show
the game here hey we recently did a
stream over on twitch talked for over
two hours about the game i'm not gonna
post that full video here but i will
link to the vod down in the description
below if you are curious about checking
out the whole thing here you can check
out some of the highlights some of the
big questions that we had some of the
conversation there and as always guys
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again very soon i think this
is going to be a big week
let's talk about this event
and what high iq warriors getting at
here
i talked about this in my last hogwarts
legacy video i think it's pretty clear
at this point we can say with about
i don't know 95 certainty that
this game playstation clearly has an
exclusivity
uh for the marketing on it now some
people in the comments were confused
like what i no it's it's coming to all
systems
that doesn't mean that it's exclusive to
playstation what it means is like when
you see the commercial it's gonna have
the playstation logo
you're gonna see it on the playstation
blog you're gonna see it on the
playstation twitter or playstation
youtube playstation twitter when you go
to youtube and you look for the hogwarts
legacy trailer it's not on a wb channel
it's not on an avalanche channel it's on
playstations channel like that's where
the official trailer is
they go silent for almost a year guys
almost nothing it all we hear is like
the uh warner media ceo he just happens
to be there and he's like hey here's
some concept art i don't think he even
knew he was giving us like
all of us fans are like oh something
thank you he gave us something
just dead silence
since the playstation showcase where
they showed the ps5 for the first time
right after that they got the blog post
then nothing all this time except the
delay of course
now
i guess it was two weeks ago now a week
and a half ago
there was a video that playstation
tweeted out
just like a little sizzle reel you know
we've seen him a million times sizzle
reel of
different games
hogwarts legacy shows up in that trailer
all footage that we've seen so far
but still that tells me it's like okay
playstation most people thought this
already by the way so this isn't like
something i just figured out don't think
that
certainly wasn't my idea most people
have been talking about this for a while
now back since it was first unveiled
maybe sony has an exclusivity deal on
the marketing for this
i think this just about confirms it
so i do for my prediction i do think it
will be there
and wb
avalanche if anybody happens to watch
this from there if it's not going to be
there
you guys need to get out in front of
this like
you need to put out a tweet
you need to put out an instagram post
this week and say
guys we know you're super excited we're
working hard the game's progressing
great here's a couple screenshots
unfortunately it will not be
at the playstation showcase we just
don't have a trailer ready yet
i'll be upset but i'll be good with that
i'll be good with that i'll understand
if they if they let this event come and
go
and say nothing
you thought fans were worried before
i'm telling you it'll be
the youtube comments will not be a
pretty place to be the twitter comments
will not be a pretty place to be it's
going to be all out
freaking out
melts meltdowns all around
now all that being said i do think it
will be there i think this is what we've
been waiting for i think they're gearing
up for it
i think we're going to get a new trailer
i do
i think we're going to see gameplay more
least a gameplay
window
at least a release window they've
already said 2022 so they're not just
going to get up there and say 2022 again
maybe they're going to say like summer
2022.
i've been on record saying i think it'd
be awesome if they kind of did something
with fantastic beasts three to sort of
release these close together
you've got a lot of opportunity for
joint marketing right there
with those two two big uh
you got the big movie and then you got
the big game hitting in the same year
so
[Music]
do a stream of the showcase padfoot i
wish i could dude i think it's at um oh
i've got it right here on screen here
yeah it'll be at 4 pm my time so i'll be
at work until 6 o'clock
but here's what i'm gonna do
like here's what i'm gonna do for you
guys this is gonna be so hard for me to
do but i'm gonna do it man
i'm gonna do it
i here's what i have to do when four
o'clock rolls around
i think
if i can um
at work i probably won't be able to i
might be able to watch some of the
showcase depends like i'm on a computer
all day at work but it depends on how
busy we are whether or not i can like
watch something
i will have it pulled up
and i'll be following on twitter
but it's soon if if i see that wb logo
i'm gonna have to log off the rest of
the day
because i have to film a live reaction
for you guys i have to
like i can't i can't watch it
and then go back and like fake it
you know
i'm not gonna do that
i i want it to be
my pure
reaction to the trailer
do you hear that to the trailer like i'm
assuming it's gonna be there
oh man if they show it
if they show it
it has to be my real reaction i feel
like i don't feel like it would be as
good if i
now don't get me wrong
we're gonna do videos after like
breaking it down here's what you missed
here's the secrets in the trailer what
does this mean
do we have a date do we have anything
like what what's extra what's new that
we've learned
but in terms of that reaction we gotta
have a video just just with me with my
initial reaction to the trailer
so yeah that's that's what i'm gonna do
man like i wish i could live stream it
if i was at home i would 100 be live
streaming it yeah i'll be at work until
six that evening so if if if they show
it
like i said i'm gonna watch the event if
i can
or follow along on twitter as soon as i
see something about a hogwarts legacy
i gotta bounce i gotta i gotta log off
social media the rest of the day
until i can get home
i get home
i'm gonna pull up the trailer i'm gonna
record
my live reaction
and i'm gonna post it that night i'm not
even gonna wait till the next day i'm
gonna post it
but yeah if i didn't have to work out a
thousand percent
we would just do we would just hang out
right here and we'd we'd watch it
together
might be beating a dead horse
if they implemented the ability to
become an anime guy i feel like that
would add such a unique way to tackle
obstacles in your animated form
yes
i agree padfoot i talked about that in
one of my videos it would certainly
present a gameplay challenge right
because
well and it's going to make a lot of
people mad because you're not going to
be able to include every animal right
some dudes like i want to be a
i'm trying to think of these uh
my son super into animals and nature
right now i'm trying to think of one of
these uh
obscure animals that they talk about oh
what is it the um
tardigrades on the show wildcats i think
it's called a tardigrade
somebody out there's gonna be like i
can't be one of those
they're gonna be so disappointed
no i think it would have to be like a
couple of animals that you could pick
from or maybe it's just decided in the
story that might be the best way to do
it and now you know that might make
people mad too though
but just like have it set like this
you're gonna become an anime agent this
is what your character will will be
or have like two or three that you can
pick from that kind of have the same
basic functionality
because once you do that
then you've got to make the game work
around it right you've got to make the
environments work around it so like
if you're a bird then can you just
suddenly fly everywhere you want
we've already seen hippogriffs in the
trailer
maybe you can i don't know
so you have to think about things like
that right
if you're a
i don't know something that can
if you're a lion can you run around like
attack things
if you're a snake can you climb in trees
but i totally agree like if they could
figure out a way to do it i think it'd
be awesome
wonder if the extra development time let
the devs squeeze in more features
gameplay elements for hogwarts legacy
that's a good question
so let's talk hogwarts legacy guys
it was announced
holy crap dude officially about a year
ago right around this moment i don't
remember the exact day i'm sure one of
you in chat remember the exact day
but it's been about a year now since we
got our official unveil now we know it's
been in development even long before
that
and they immediately said
so they had to be feeling
at least somewhat confident
about where the game was at right
so they say 2021
then we get into 2021 and like the first
month january they're like nope is
delayed
which i know coven and all that that
certainly affected a lot of things but i
don't think that was the only thing
so did they fit in more features
i'm going to make my guess here
i'm going to say
they they ended up being a lot further
than they realized but i do think they
use this time to fit in something extra
and you want to tell me you want me to
tell you what i think they they fit in
i'm gonna i'm gonna stir the pot here
dude this one gets hogwarts this one
gets hogwarts legacy pants going like
nothing else
multiplayer
yeah yeah multiplayer
now before you panic the single player
folks are like no multiplayer
no no no no no this is an action rpg
and i agree it is
it is
but
after the game was announced i think
they saw so many people talking about
man i would love to play this
co-op with my friend or something
then i think even if it's not at launch
i think they're going to add some sort
of multiplayer component whether it's
down the line it doesn't have to be at
launch
but i do think they will add
some sort of cooperative and or
multiplayer component
don't know when
but i think they will
i mean it helps the longevity of the
game too
right
how'd the multiplayer even work
i think it would have to be something
that's
not completely different from the main
game but if you've played ghosts of
tsushima or you've heard about ghost of
tsushima
this one came out of nowhere
nobody knew about this maybe maybe they
did somewhere and it was rumored i i
didn't hear anything about this but
ghost of tsushima is a very strong
single player
it's not an rpg but it's got it's got um
like upgrade elements to it it's a great
game by the way if you haven't played it
huge game open world
and then like a month or two after
launch they're like oh by the way
here's a free multiplayer update and
they just dropped it
they just dropped this multiplayer
update that was like a i haven't played
it but i've actually heard it's really
good too it's like a raid-like activity
so it's of course using the same engine
and everything but the missions and all
it's completely separate you go in with
a group of people
and you work through these raid-like
activities if you ever play destiny it's
nowhere near as kind of robust as those
types of raids but it's that similar
idea
so something like that i think would be
i think would be great and i know
anytime you bring this up like there's
there's people on both sides of the
aisle some people are so mad that it's
already action rpg they're like what
it's not an mmo i want to go around
hogwarts with my friends and other
people are like no stop sit down
it's an action rpg that's what we want
but i'm like guys
we can kind of both get
a little bit of what we want maybe not
the mmo folks it's not going to be an
mmo
but i think there could definitely be
some co-op to it yeah
scrub work definitely think they will
too
might have just added in the framework
for potential expansion co-op right it
doesn't even have to be in the shipped
game that they put out
even to a separate game completely like
gta online yeah i mean
they certainly could
hopefully visit places that you'd only
know about it if you read the books like
the kitchens and such
the kitchens
the kitchens and the house elves
absolutely need to begin
all i agree
they kind of already confirmed house
elves
i i shouldn't say confirmed they didn't
confirm it but they they talked about
house elves in that playstation blog
article
they mentioned the house elves and like
talking about how old does a house self
live or something or some of the
questions that they're thinking about
so i'm like why would you
you know if those are the kinds of
questions they're asking and he's
dropping the line house elves
surely they're actually gonna be in the
game
i mean imagine how awesome that would be
like if you just like
if you can go into the kitchens
and see like the house elves just like
working as they're preparing the food
the expulsion my heavy shook right
it looks like an axe or something that
just
right into the chest of a goblin
[Music]
maybe that's what they show at the
showcase but in better quality
hopefully it's some gameplay moments
like that yeah
oh dude i can't wait man
now i'm getting my my hopes up and it's
not going to show up
it's not going to show up
oh man i'm going to tweet at wb tomorrow
and avalanche would be like guys
you really need to get ahead of this
if it's not going to be there please
please get ahead of this because we fans
are so
hyped and ready for something
all right so let's talk this playstation
event other than hogwarts legacy like i
said i do think it's going to be there
i'd be super disappointed if it's not
if it's not
my recommendation
for whatever it's worth
which isn't much but for for whatever
it's worth i think wb and avalanche
absolutely need to get out ahead of it
tweet like tomorrow guys tuesday and say
not gonna be there here's a couple
screenshots
we're working on it it's going well
development's pressing fine
can't wait to show you something
holidays of this year or early next year
whatever just you got to give us
something this week
wb you got to give us something
overall though at this playstation event
i mean let's start with the obvious ones
the first party stuff obviously god of
war
we got to get an update on god of war
i'm sure horizon will be a big focus as
well
all right so i've got a website called
push square pulled up here i'm gonna see
what their predictions are
this is just for the overall event
all right so they're uh realistic
prediction naughty dogs the last of us
multiplayer game will finally be hey i
threw that one out
i threw that one out i would i would be
i feel like that one is
likely i'll say likely
sammy wants more than what we know about
already
okay never mind that's not really a
prediction
here's one sony will announce new
playstation plus incentives
i hadn't thought about that but i like
that
as as the
game pass gets more and more just
appealing like lots of focus on game
pass and how awesome it is which it is
i guess i can definitely see them
announcing some new playstation plus
stuff
the new final fantasy gets a march 2022
release date
gta 5 these are predictions by the way
guys from push square gta 5's ps5
version will finally be shown off
yeah that seems kind of safe
motor storm that's kind of off the wall
gran turismo 7 shares new game play and
a tight release window
metal gear solid remake developed by
blue point games
okay you want to know my pie in the sky
my like
totally freak out i would lose my mind
is if they announced a
bloodborne remake
from blue point
i'm a huge bloodborne fan guys
it's a shame they haven't updated that
game for ps5
just up the frame rate is all i need
just unlock the frame rate frame rate
the art style is already phenomenal just
unlock the frame rate for us please
but
if you're not gonna do that
a blue point remake would be phenomenal
metal gear solid remake though i think
that one's like kind of a big groomer
though right
i think that's kind of a big but they've
already remade metal gear solid like how
many times
don't get me wrong i like metal gear but
i like bloodborne a whole heck of a lot
more
so yeah those are some predictions
that's kind of what people are thinking
some of those are realistic and then
some of those were considered dream
predictions uh if you're not already sub
to the youtube channel head on over
there youtube.com retro racket tour
check it out we got a ton of hogwarts
legacy content over there and more
to come
more to come guys
this has been a blast hope you all have
a fantastic evening
uh have a fantastic rest of your week
and i will talk to you all again
soon